hey guys recently I had a person ask me
the question how can you make it easier
to stick to a key tell an intermittent
fasting program are there any tips okay
and so I asked I asked them back
what are you running into what throws
you off okay so I'm gonna go through all
the objections one by one but really the
question is for you if you're having a
hard time sticking to this what throws
you off isolate the barrier because
there are solutions to every single
barrier I'm gonna cover quite a few
right here I think the biggest thing is
results you've tried all these things in
the past they haven't worked and now
here's the next thing and in your mind
like oh that's probably not going to
work but what I want to do is I want to
present a new concept to you the concept
is it's not lose weight to get healthy
it's get healthy to lose the weight
shift your goal to getting healthy
forget the weight because you're gonna
find out the weight loss is gonna come
with getting healthy that concept it was
really really effective but you're
focusing just on the weight you're gonna
set yourself up for a lot of failure
because weight loss is a byproduct of
getting healthy especially if it's
healthy weight loss all right so what
throws you off is it bread well there's
a lot of recipes for alternative breads
that you can consume so that's gonna be
easy hunger your hunger is gonna go away
when you do this because we're gonna
drop insulin you're gonna burn your own
fat the hunger is gonna go away it's
gonna take about three to seven days
before it goes away but when you adapt
no more hunger no more cravings that's
gonna really increase your ability to
stick with it scheduling maybe you eat
run a certain time and your family eats
around a certain time and it's not
convenient blah blah blah well what do
you do in a minute fasting the frequency
of eating is shortened and you can you
can stick that eating plan anywhere in
your schedule it doesn't have to be in a
certain time it's actually actually
going to be very easy the scheduling is
going to be very simple because you're
not eating six meals a day you're eating
less frequent so it's going to be easier
on your schedule
alright depriving yourself of certain
carbs you could have a lot of
alternatives that mimic the carbohydrate
for mashed potatoes bread cookies any of
these biscuits there are so many things
that you can substitute that you will
never feel deprived I'll put a link down
below and I do it I do know what people
mean but because when you tell them you
can't have something they want it more
and plus you're gonna do this on a very
slow gradual pace so it's not a shock to
your system or your you're not gonna
feel like oh my gosh I'm starving it's
not gonna be the case let's say you're
bored with eating the same thing over
and over
well that's why there's a recipe books
there's a ton of ones we have some
Kindle recipe books that give you a lot
of choices I'll put some links down
below it's expensive well no actually
it's not when you cut down the frequency
of eating oh my gosh your your grocery
bill is gonna go way down you can save
four to five to six hundred dollars a
month on doing this so it's very
inexpensive and then take that a little
bit of that extra and focus on the
quality of your foods you don't like
salad well just buy it predigested no
that's impossible
get something to chew it for you that's
probably not gonna work either but that
is one thing that you're gonna have to
bite the bullet okay and you're gonna
have to figure it out I think once you
start doing it and maybe blend your kale
with the shake or start doing it on a
smaller scale I think you may begin to
want it more and more because a lot of
people like the they don't like salads
but we start consuming it they feel so
much better they're like huh I can do
this so it is a small barrier to
overcome but you are going to have to
consume more vegetable side effects keto
flu fatigued keto rash if you understand
how to do this correctly because you've
studied it and you know how to do it
you're not gonna have to go through this
and that's why I recommend read a book
on it get the knowledge of it don't just
do it you know halfway learn how to do
this and prepare and do it right because
you can actually
set yourself up for a lot of good things
versus a lot of bad things I'll just
give you an example when you start going
Quito you're gonna dump a lot of fluid
okay you're gonna lose a lot of fluid
water weight probably leaven 212 pounds
of fluid and then you're gonna Plateau
well with the fluid comes out a lot of
electrolytes potassium sodium but you're
gonna lose a lot more potassium than
sodium okay so then you may feel
dehydrated so you someone told you to
drink more water so now you're gonna
drink all this water right guess what
that's gonna do to the small amount
electrolytes it's gonna dilute them even
more so now we went from a potassium
deficiency to a severe potassium
deficiency then you get leg cramps you
get restless leg your heart rate goes up
you can't sleep at night palpitations
all because you did not understand
what's happening and how to do this
correctly so like I said you will can
avoid these if you spend the time get a
book study how to do this all right too
restrictive actually it's restricting
really one thing we're fine
carbohydrates and sugars but there's
alternatives so you're not gonna feel
like it's too restrictive now there are
certain diets that will use that
objection and tell you oh yeah guess
what this is the chocolate diet or this
diet you can eat all the food you want
just in moderation and you'll go for it
it won't work so the point is that you
want something that really works then
you're gonna have to change something
okay confusing well again it's only
confusing because you're getting
conflicting information you're searching
the web and you're going from this
person over here and this person stick
with one program one person and study
them completely and then do their
program try not to get too much extra
information because you're never gonna
find something that everyone agrees 100%
on because people have different
viewpoints so again that's what I would
recommend for that not sure it's gonna
work I do understand that you probably
tried a lot of
programs in the past that didn't work
and but the bottom line is you're never
going to know if it's gonna work unless
you try it and you have to change what
you're doing I will say from personal
experience working with a lot of people
29 years of doing this this program that
I'm presenting works amazingly well
it is hands-down one of the most
effective programs I've ever put out
there and I'm seeing the results okay so
bite the bullet try it out and I think
you can make it easy to stick to this
long term hey guys I wanted to
personally invite you to a new Facebook
group that I just started called dr.
Berg's Kido and in a minute fasting lab
okay so I created this so we can share
our successful actions what worked what
didn't work your results so I put a link
down below so go ahead and sign up and
I'll see you inside